BLASTS HAVE BEEN REPORTED IN THE
CAPITAL CITY OF KYIV ALSO IN THE
WESTERN CITY OF LVIV AND IN
THEEST EASTERN CITY OF DNIPRO
AND ZAPORIZHZHIA AS WELL.
OFFICIALS SAY AT LEAST FIVE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED, AT
LEAST 12 INJURED.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR MORE
NUMBERS ON THAT.
VIDEO HERE, THIS IS A PEDESTRIAN
BRIDGE IN KYIV, A NEARBY STRIKE
DAMAGING IT WITH THIS EXPLOSION
HERE.
A MISSILE ALSO HIT A CHILDREN'S
PLAYGROUND.
YOU CAN SEE THE CRATER THAT IT
LEFT HERE.
THE MAYOR OF KYIV IS WARNING
PEOPLE TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
>>> THIS MORNING THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT, VLADIMIR PUTIN, HELD
A NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
MEETING AFTER ACCUSING UKRAINE
OF CARRYING OUT A TERROR ATTACK
THAT DAMAGED THAT BRIDGE THAT
LINKS RUSSIA AND RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED CRIMEA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> Translator: WE HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT THIS IS A TERRORIST ATTACK
AIMED AT THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
AND AUTHORS, EXECUTORS AND
MASTER MINDS ARE THE SECRET
SERVICE OF UKRAINE.
>> UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS HAVE NOT
CLAIMED RESPONSIBILITY.
MEANWHILE, THERE IS GROWING
CONCERN THAT RUSSIA IS GEARING
UP TO USE TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, HOWEVER THE KREMLIN
SAID THAT IT IS COMPLETELY
INCORRECT, IN THEIR WORDS, TO
SUGGEST THAT MOSCOW WOULD USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN RETALIATION.
>> CNN'S FREDERIK PLEITGEN IS
LIVE IN KYIV AND HE'S ACTUALLY
NEAR WHERE ONE OF THE MISSILES
STRUCK.
TELL US WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
THERE, FRED.
>> Reporter: I'M ACTUALLY A
COUPLE OF FEET FROM WHERE ONE OF
THE MISSILES STRUCK.
I'M GOING TO GET OUT OF YOUR WAY
QUICKLY AND YOU CAN SEE THE
MASSIVE IMPACT CRATER THE
MISSILE LEFT BEHIND.
IT'S NOT ONLY VERY WIDE BUT IT'S
VERY DEEP AS WELL.
IT'S TORN THROUGH THE TARMAC,
THE UPPER LAYER OF THE ROAD
THERE AND JUST BLASTED RIGHT
INTO THE STREET.
NOW JUST A COUPLE OF MINUTES
AGO, THE UKRAINE'S ARE CLEANING
UP RIGHT NOW BUT THERE WERE A
LOT OF DESTROYED CARS HERE AND
ONE DEAD BODY THAT WE SAW THE
R
RECOVERY AND RESCUE CREWS
TAKEAWAY.
I WOULD SAY IT WAS AROUND MAYBE
QUARTER PAST EIGHT LOCAL TIME,
ABOUT 1:15 ON THE EAST COAST
THAT THE FIRST EXPLOSION TOOK
PLACE.
AS THE MORNING PROGRESSED WE
HEARD EXPLOSION AFTER EXPLOSION
AS THE RUSSIANS WERE APPARENTLY
HITTING THE CAPITAL CITY HERE IN
KYIV WITH THE ROCKETS, MISSILES,
THE UKRAINIANS APPARENTLY
INTERCEPTING THOSE AS WELL.
WE GOT THE FOOTAGE IN FROM THE
UKRAINES SHOWING SOME OF THE
MISSILES THEY SAY THEY
INTERCEPTED ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF
KYIV.
BUT THE AIR-RAID SIRENS WERE
GOING ON FOR A LONG TIME AND THE
KYIV MAYOR IS TELLING PEOPLE NOT
TO COME TO THE CITY, NOT TO
VENTURE OUT.
PEOPLE WHO LIVE ON THE
OUTSKIRTS.
AND THEN COMING INTO THE CITY TO
WORK, TELLING THEM NOT TO COME
AS WELL.
IT'S A SIMILAR PICTURE IN LARGE
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY HERE, OF
UKRAINE, WHERE SEVERAL CITIES
HAVE BEEN HIT.
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT HAS SAID
HE BELIEVES THAT THERE WERE TWO
TARGETS, ESSENTIALLY, THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAD.
ONE WAS UKRAINIAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE, THERE'S A BUNCH
OF PLACES WITHOUT POWER, PART OF
THE CITY OF KYIV IS ALSO WITHOUT
POWER AS WELL.
BUT ALSO UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
IF YOU LOOK BEHIND ME, WHAT YOU
SEE THERE IS A ROAD JUNCTION.
THERE WERE A BUNCH OF CARS
THERE, PEOPLE CROSSING THE ROAD
AS WELL.
AND ALL OF THIS HAPPENED AT
AROUND QUARTER PAST EIGHT, HALF
PAST EIGHT, WHICH IN ANY MAYOR
CITY IS A TIME OF RUSH HOUR AND
A TIME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WORK.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE AND I'VE SEEN
IT MYSELF AS THESE CITIES GET
PUMMELLED, THE CREWS COME OUT SO
QUICKLY TO CLEAN UP AND TRY TO
GET LIFE BACK TO NORMAL.
THIS IS, OF COURSE, THE LEAST
POSSIBLE TIME IN UKRAINE.
FREDERIK PLEITGEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR REPORTING THIS MORNING, YOU
AND YOUR TEAM STAY SAFE OUT
THERE.
>> I WANT TO GO TO NICK PATON
WALSH.
HE IS LIVE FOR US IN SOUTHERN
UKRAINE.
NICK, THE STRIKES THAN
WIDESPREAD, WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THIS.
THEY'VE BEEN ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN SEEING ON THE
GROUND?
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONVEY TO
PEOPLE THAT FOR A WHILE THIS
MORNING IT FELT LIKE ALL OF
UKRAINE WAS ESSENTIALLY UNDER
MISSILE ATTACK.
AND NOW THAT SIRENS ARE
STOPPING, PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK
OUT FROM THEIR SHELTERS.
IT'S CLEAR THERE WERE LESS
TARGETS BUT I THINK THE IMPACT
OF RUSSIA'S ATTACK WAS DESIGNED
TO MAKE SO MANY UKRAINIANS CALL
THEIR FRIENDS, CALL THEIR FAMILY
AND REALLY FEAR THAT SOMETHING
MASSIVE WAS AFOOT.
CLEARLY THIS IS SOME OF THE
WORST VIOLENCE INFLICTED ON THE
COUNTRY SINCE THE START OF THE
WAR.
BUT SOME OF THE TARGETS SEEM TO
HAVE BEEN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE PRESIDENT'S HOMETOWN ARE
EXPERIENCING POWER CUTS AFTER
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS HIT BY ONE
EXPLOSION.
FOR A WHILE THERE WERE DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT MORE DRONES
HEADED THEIR WAY.
WE WERE WITH PEOPLE IN THE
SUBWAY SHELTERING FROM THAT.
WHERE WE'RE HEADED TO IN DNIPRO
THERE ARE REPORTS OF TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HITTING THERE AS
WELL.
A ROCKET LANDING NEAR A BUS,
MIRACULOUSLY NOBODY ON THE BUS
HURT SAID UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS.
THIS IS A CHANGE IN TACTICS FROM
THE KREMLIN AFTER THE BRIDGE
ATTACK AND THE SERIES OF
MILITARY DEFEATS THEY'VE BEEN
REELING FROM FRANKLY OVER THE
PAST MONTHS.
THEY HAVE A NEW RUSSIAN MILITARY
COMMANDER NOW.
HE IS A MAN WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR A LOT OF ATTACKS AGAINST
CIVILIANS WHEN RUSSIA'S MILITARY
INTERVENTION IN SYRIA HAPPENED
AND ACCUSED OF USE OF OTHER
WEAPONS THERE TOO.
BUT THE FACT THIS HAS HAPPENED
ON ONE DAY ACROSS THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY IS DESIGNED TO SEND TO
MESSAGES ONE THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAS CARDS STILL TO PLAY AND ONE
TO UKRAINE'S PEOPLE THEY ARE
STILL VULNERABLE, SO MANY CITIES
GOING BACK TO NORMAL LIFE BUT
STILL A SENSE OF DEFIANCE HERE
PEOPLE WONDERING WHAT ELSE CAN
BE THROWN AT THEM.
BACK TO YOU.
>> THAT NEW COMMANDER, GLAD YOU
POINTED THAT OUT.
THANK YOU, NICK.
>>> JOINING US FROM KYIV IS
MICHAEL DOWNEY, AN AMERICAN
PHOTO JOURNALIST WHO WAS BLOCKED
AWAY FROM ONE OF THE BLASTS THIS
MORNING IN KYIV.
MICHAEL, YOU GOT TO KYIV A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO.
IT'S BEEN QUIET FOR MONTHS.
TELL US WHAT YOU SAW AND YOU
HEARD TODAY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN
VERY QUIET SINCE I ARRIVED HERE
A FEW WEEKS AGO, A WEEK AGO,
THERE HAVE BEEN AIR-RAID SIRENS
BUT MOST PEOPLE GO ABOUT THEIR
DAY AS NORMAL.
THERE WERE SOME EARLIER IN THE
MORNING AND IT WAS QUIET.
I WAS JUST WAKING UP, ABOUT 8:00
A.M., AND I HEARD THE MISSILE
COME RIGHT BY -- RIGHT BY OUR
HOTEL.
AND THEN IMPACTED, YOU KNOW,
JUST A FEW BLOCKS AWAY.
AND I MEAN, WE ARE -- I THINK
EVERYBODY WAS COMPLETELY
SHOCKED.
THERE WAS SOME EXPECTATION THAT
THERE WOULD BE A RESPONSE FROM
RUSSIA AFTER THE BRIDGE
CONNECTING CRIMEA AND RUSSIA WAS
HIT YESTERDAY.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WAS
QUITE PREPARED FOR THIS LEVEL OF
INDISCRIMINATE ROCKET ATTACKS IN
CIVILIAN AREAS ON A BUSY MONDAY
MORNING.
>> MORE THAN 80 MISSILES WE
UNDERSTAND SO FAR.
AND LIKE SO MANY OTHERS YOU WENT
DOWN INTO A BOMB SHELTER.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
WHAT WAS THE MOOD DOWN THERE?
WHAT WERE PEOPLE SAYING?
>> NORMALLY BEFORE PEOPLE
WEREN'T USING THESE BUNKERS FOR
THE PAST FEW MONTHS IT'S BEEN
VERY QUIET IN KYIV.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME IN A
WHILE YOU'D SEE THESE PLACES
REALLY PACKED.
BUT THE MOOD, YOU KNOW,
UKRAINIANS UNFORTUNATELY ARE SO
USED TO THIS WAR AND THESE
ATTACKS AND VERY QUICKLY PEOPLE
WERE MAKING COFFEE, PASSING
AROUND SNACKS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, AT THE SAME TIME,
LOOKING AT NEWS AND UPDATES FOR
WHEN THE NEXT WAVE WAS COMING.
WE'D HEAR UPDATES THAT FIVE MORE
CRUISE MISSILES WERE FIRED FROM
THE BLACK SEA OR THESE DRONES
WERE LAUNCHED FROM BELARUS.
SO EVERYONE WAS CALCULATING WHEN
THEY WOULD HIT, DEBATING WHEN IT
MIGHT BE SAFE TO GO OUT.
FINALLY JUST A LITTLE OVER TWO
HOURS AGO WE WERE GIVEN THE ALL
CLEAR.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE SIRENS WERE
GOING ON FOR AROUND SIX HOURS.
YOU'RE OUT OF THE SHELTER NOW.
DO YOU THINK PEOPLE WILL GO BACK
TO LIVING THOSE RELATIVELY
NORMAL LIVES OR IS THERE GOING
TO BE SOME TREPIDATION, FEAR
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN TODAY?
>> I THINK A BIT OF CAUTION.
BUT IT'S REMARKABLE, ALREADY NOT
TOO LONG AFTER, THERE WERE
PEOPLE LINING UP FOR CAFES,
SITTING OUTSIDE, WALKING THEIR
DOGS.
UKRAINIANS AREN'T LETTING THIS
GET IN THE WAY OF THEIR EVERYDAY
LIFE.
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT
INTIMIDATED BY RUSSIA'S TACTICS.
SO IT IS REMARKABLE SEEING THE
RESILIENCE OF THE CITY.
YEAH, IT'S -- YOU KNOW, LIFE
GOES ON.
THERE'S DEFINITELY -- SORRY,
THERE IS SOME CONCERN DEFINITELY
WE'RE TOLD LATER TONIGHT, AROUND
7:30, 8:00 P.M. WE'RE TOLD THERE
WILL BE A RESUMING, ANOTHER WAVE
OF ATTACKS.
>> WE'RE THANKFUL YOU'RE SAFE,
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
MICHAEL DOWNEY IN KYIV.
APPRECIATE IT.